you've done a lot of cool things in your
career if someone has never seen
anything you've done before what is the
thing you want them watching first and
why
um probably an unpopular choice but um
I would say pieces of a woman just
because only because I was so proud that
um a birth and you know a kind of live
birth was on screen
for a quarter of the screen time and at
the time when we were filming it I
realized that there have been thousands
of deaths on screen and hardly any birth
and yet as humans we all born and we all
die and so that felt very special as a
female writer who wrote it to write that
to film that it felt um you know I felt
very very honored to do that uh I'm
curious I'm so looking forward to Ridley
Scott's Napoleon which I know you're not
here to promote but he works can you
talk a little bit about the way Ridley
Works versus the way Chris works because
there's such different styles yet they
both create amazing movies they do it's
complete polar opposite Chris you will
do 40 or 50 takes you can do any you
know play around it might just be in one
single shot
he will ask so many different things of
you you'll do that and then uh with
um
with Ridley
you do he shoots and you know maybe six
cameras
and you'll do a couple of takes because
he catches it from every angle so he
says it's like theater because you can
you know shoot a scene and he'll capture
every single image then you can move on
so it's almost the opposite really like
what can you tease people about it
though because I'm so excited to see
Joaquin I've seen some footage I just
looks yeah Tom Tom brings a Crowd Oh
yeah it doesn't he he's the best
um what can I tell you about the movie
It's epic Joaquin is extraordinary and
it's a you know Ridley's finest
historical biopic really it's got
incredible battles
an amazing character study like Joaquin
does and it was a pleasure it was a
pleasure to do it I loved it jumping
back into Mission uh this movie and set
it to you on camera yesterday it's
incredible there are so many awesome
Parts what what's like what are you most
excited for audiences to see in this uh
I think um
God I think the character's side is in
it honestly you have Hayley he's got
this whole backstory
you know you have Rebecca and her oh her
immense power you have these amazing
women in it pawn being so Fierce and
then I think you have an Ethan who I
don't know you have an Ethan who is um
doubting you know himself and his life
and it's all catching up with him and I
think that's really special because as
humans I think we all feel
flawed and doubtful and you know you've
got an Ethan Hunt who's the kind of
superhero to me and he's really I think
feeling the weight of the journey he's
gone on so I'm excited for that I know
you have to do a lot more interviews so
I'm just going to let you go I'm just
going to say uh wish you nothing but the
best movie's awesome thank you